the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lesson today involves a rather
subtle difference between a curve and a
coordinate system in other words given a
curve that curve has a certain shape has
a certain position independently of
where our coordinate axes are if we're
using Cartesian coordinates or whether
we're using other coordinate systems or
what-have-you but the equation of the
curve may very well depend on what
coordinate system we're using you say
the thing that we would like to do in
this particular lecture is to hit a very
important highlight that comes up well
you can motivate it from a purely
mathematical point of view but
physically there's an even more natural
interpretation and basically what the
thing hinges on is this if you're given
a curve in space we'll start with a
curve in the plane but it applies to
curves in space as well and that is
given that curve in the plane does that
curve have certain properties regardless
of whether you know what your coordinate
system is or not or in still other words
can you measure the shape of the curve
can you measure the speed along the
curve as a particle traverses it if you
had never heard of the X and y
coordinate system and what this leads to
is a new system of vectors by which we
study motion in space called tangential
and normal vectors when we're dealing in
the plane and as a third member called
the by normal vector which we'll talk
about later when we deal in
three-dimensional space any rate just
for brevity I call this lecture
tangential and normal vectors and the
idea is something like this we're given
a curve C now given this particular
curve C it happens that we have a
Cartesian coordinate system here and it
also happens that we prefer at least as
we've done things in the past we write
everything in terms of I and J
components notice that if a person were
restricted to his universe being the
curve C I and J have no basic meaning to
him what does have a basic meaning to
him as he's moving along this curve
I would imagine would be what what is
his motion tangential to the curve in
other words if you want to look at this
from a calculus point of view if this is
a smooth curve in a sufficiently small
neighborhood of this point you cannot
distinguish between the curve and the
tangent line and consequently one could
interpret that at a given instant the
motion was always along the straight
line tangential to the curve what this
leads to is the notion of inventing what
we call a unit tangent vector which I'll
call T all right and what does that
tangent vector it's not a constant mind
you it shifts with position as you move
along the curve what is constant is its
magnitude it has constant magnitude one
I guess what I'm trying to say in sort
of a surrealistic or meta mathematical
way is that T plays to a person who's
living on the curve see the same role
that I plays to a person living in our
ordinary space that somehow or other he
sees T is a constant vector as he moves
along the curve if he visualizes the
curve is being a straight line he always
sees it tangential to his motion now in
the same way that J was a 90 degree
clockwise rotation of I one would like
to mimic the I and J Cartesian
coordinate system by inventing another
unit vector which is again what a
positive 90 degree rotation of T and
we'll call that vector n so that now we
have a new system of coordinates T and n
new system of variables are vectors
whereby we can now study motion along a
curve in a very natural way in other
words we talk about the unit tangent
direction and the unit normal direction
all right we have this thing now
established what we would like to do is
to see what happens in our study of
kinematics motion in the plane motion in
space if we work in terms of tangential
and normal components now rather than in
terms of I and J components the first
thing that we probably like to do is
figure out how in the world
compute T well for example let's take a
particular application let's take the
example that we were dealing with last
time where we had the radius vector R in
other words the scalar function T where
TD know the time and we were dealing
with what motion in space where the
radius vector R was a function of T and
remember what we showed last time we
showed that the R DT the velocity vector
has its what it's Direction is always
tangent to the curve we proved that last
time well look at as long as the R DT is
always tangent to the curve what
prevents it from being a unit tangent
vector well nothing prevents it from
being a tangent vector because it's
already tangent to the curve all that
could go wrong is that the magnitude of
di DT is not 1 well look at that's again
a very simple point to fix up namely if
the magnitude of di DT is not 1 suppose
we divide that vector by its magnitude
we have already seen that given any
non-zero vector if you divide that
vector by its magnitude you get the unit
vector in the same direction as the
vector that you started with in other
words if I take the vector di DT which
is already tangential to the curve at
the given point and I divide that by the
magnitude of the R DT then I
automatically get the unit tangent
vector is that clear
since nobody says no I assume it is
clear look we also showed last time that
the magnitude of the I DT is speed along
the curve speed along the curve happens
to be called D s DT so again another
name for the unit tangent vector is dr
dt divided by the s dt by the chain rule
we can cancel dt and by the way notice
the chain rule applies for vector
functions like this the same as it did
in part 1 of our course by virtue of
what we showed in the last unit namely
that every formula for derivatives that
was true for scalar functions also
happen to be true for what vector
functions of a scale
variable at any rate notice them by the
chain rule another way of saying T is
that it's the position vector the
derivative of the position vector R with
respect to the arc length s I'd like to
make one comment on this it's important
enough so that I will also make this
comment in the notes as well when we're
doing the exercises the point is that in
many textbooks they will define T by
saying it's DRDs now 999 times out of a
thousand in fact 999 times out of 998
even you will never be given R as a
function of Ocwen in the real world in
the real world R is a function of some
parameter usually time and the trouble
that happens is if you try to use this
definition you find yourself trying to
convert things into s and this makes
sort of a mess for you the thing I would
like to show you and by the way this
does not depend on T standing for time
if T is any variable and we show this in
the notes in the exercises again if T is
any scalar if you differentiate R with
respect to that scalar and divide that
result by the magnitude of this vector
you wind up with the unit tangent vector
in other words in a real life problem do
not worrying about converting R into a
function of s simply differentiate R as
it stands with respect to the given
variable divided by the magnitude of the
derivative and presto you have the unit
tangent vector of course you may ask if
it's so simple to do what I just said
why is it that every book defines it
this way the answer is rather
interesting and that is we have just
mentioned that we would like to believe
that the shape of a curve depends only
on the curve itself not on how we
parameterize it the beauty of this
particular definition simply says look
at the natural parameter is Auckland
namely arc length doesn't depend on any
coordinate system given the curve start
at any point you want and you can
measure the arc length so S is a very
natural parameter that does not depend
on the coordinate system in other words
by defining the unit tangent vector to
be dr DS you have a
beautiful philosophically pure
mathematical definition because you have
a definition which does not depend on
any coordinate system or any unnatural
parameter but in practice this is the
way we compute the unit tangent vector
question that comes up is how do you
find the vector N and I'm going to show
you the traditional way of doing this
before I jazz it up with a more modern
approach look at let's look at T over
here let's call fie the angle that the
unit tangent vector makes with the curve
here okay
notice that in terms of this diagram
since the unit tangent vector has
magnitude 1 the eye component of it will
be cosine fee and the J component will
be sine fee in other words T is equal to
cosine Phi plus sine 3j let's just
differentiate you see T is that function
the fee here let's just take the
derivative of T with respect to fee and
we get right away see member now we're
getting the mileage out of this basic
definition of derivative that hasn't
changed since last time we just
differentiate term by term here we get
minus sine Phi I plus cosine V J right
away we observe that DT DV is still a
unit vector you see its components are
minus sine Phi and cosine fee so it's
magnitude is still 1 all right and it's
slope is cosine fee over minus sine fee
which is the negative reciprocal of the
slope here in other words what this
shows us through the traditional
approach is that whatever vector DT DV
is it's a unit vector perpendicular to T
by the way what that tells us right away
is that the TD fee must be the plus + or
minus and before we go any further why
because we already saw that positive n
at the vector that we called n was a
positive 90 degree rotation of T if we
only knew that the TD fee was a positive
90 degree rotation rather than a
negative 90 degree rotation would be
home free and again the beauty of
trigonometry in the non surveyors sense
of the word analytically is this that
sort of having a premonition of what
we'd like to be true we simply verify
the trigonometric
identities that the cosine of fee plus
ninety degrees is minus sign fee and the
sign of fee plus ninety degrees is
cosign fee so that the TD fee is what
it's cosine fee plus 90 degrees I plus
sign fee plus 90 degrees J and if we now
compare this with this we notice that we
have exactly the same expression except
that the angle has been increased by a
positive 90 degrees in other words dtdv
is a positive 90 degree rotation of T
consequently dtdv is the vector that was
called n okay that's dtdv now let's go
back to our kinematics we have TN n now
let's talk about our velocity vector V
where R is still some function of time
by definition V is di DT that isn't
going to change V was the IDT last time
it's going to be di DT this time it's
going to be dr/dt whenever we want to
use it the only difference is is that
instead of expressing this in terms of I
and J we now want to express it in terms
of T and N and notice that since V has
as its direction the direction of the
tangent line and as its magnitude dsdt
we saw that last time notice that in
terms of T V is just a scalar multiple
of the unit tangent vector T and what
scalar multiple is it it's the sdt all
right all that says is what that V is
the vector in the direction of T whose
magnitude is the SD T which is speed
along the curve I now want to find a a
is acceleration it's the same
acceleration that I was talking about
before
it's DV DT the only thing that's going
to change now is I am NOT going to
change the acceleration vector I am
going to change how it looks because now
I'm going to try to find it in terms of
T and n components so what do I do here
look look at this expression for V the
SD T is speed along the curve that
changes from time to time in general the
unit tangent vector T is also a variable
function of T unless T happens to be a
straight line through the origin
namely notice that the unit tangent
vector even though it always has unit
length changes its direction as we move
along the curve so in other words both
of these fact factors are functions of T
consequently to differentiate this with
respect to T we must use the product
rule and the fact that all of our
differentiation formulas are true for
vector and scalar combinations as well
as for scalars I now use the regular
product rule namely it's the derivative
of the first factor times the second
plus the first factor times the
derivative of the second and I now have
a expressed in terms of two vectors T
and the derivative of the unit vector T
with respect to time T and somehow or
other all that's wrong here is I would
like to get this thing expressed in
terms of n you see when I'm working with
T and n components I want my answer to
depend on T and n now here's where I
become very shrewd and by the way this
is an insight that you if you're going
to pick it up at all
you either born with it or you pick it
up with experience but you just have to
work with these things there are tricks
if you want I guess
the knot the novice calls them tricks
the experts calls it cause a keen
analytical insight the point is look at
I want to get an N out of this thing I
already know how to express n in terms
of DT DT in fact n is DTD fie so what I
do is I take DT DT and say let me write
it so I can get a DTD fee factor out of
this I also want everything to be in
terms of arc length so like and
ultimately have an answer which doesn't
depend on a coordinate system so what I
really do is is I use the chain rule to
express this factor in terms of what
these three factors you see according to
the chain rule the de here cancels the
defeat here the d s here cancels the DS
here and all I'm saying is that DT DT
can be written as DT DV times defeat es
times the s DT now we're in very good
shape you see DT DV we already know is N
and the s/dt we already know can go with
this and the only new thing that we have
to worry about is what is defeat es see
again what so often happens you apply
logic you get to a certain inescapable
conclusion and then if you have brand
new terms you have a choice between
doing what saying I don't like the new
terms I'm going to throw them away or
saying I like the result I had better
interpret what this new term means all I
want to show you is is that the feed es
has a very natural interpretation namely
what is defeat the s let me tell you
what it's called first it's usually
denoted by the Greek letter Kappa and
it's called curvature it's reciprocal 1
over Kappa is usually denoted by Rho and
it's called the radius of curvature and
I give you plenty of drill on this stuff
I just want to mention what these words
are now in fact part of the drill is
that the feed es is not a very
convenient thing to compute usually a
given Y is some function of X and many
of the drill problems that we have in
calculus ask questions like how do you
express the feed es in terms of y dy DX
etc those are problems that we can get
into in more detail as we do the
exercises but all I want to do in this
lecture is to show you why DeFede es is
such a natural thing look at the curve s
as you move along this curve notice that
the change in fee with respect to s in a
way tells you how the shape of the curve
is changing in other words DeFede es
measures how what could be a more
intangible word than curvature c as fee
changes as you move along the curve
that's measuring how your curvature is
changing as an extreme extreme case
notice if the curve were a straight line
the fee D s would be zero right because
fee would be a constant DeFede es would
be zero and the curvature of a straight
line should be zero at any rate one
defines DeFede es to be the curvature
and in fact to play it safely since s
can have two different senses in other
words why couldn't somebody else say why
don't you go this way along the curve I
own or the sense is you
one does to play it safe is we put the
absolute value signs around the defeat
es and just call the magnitude the
curvature and the punchline is that once
I call the feed es the curvature what I
wind up with is what just substituting
in here now the acceleration vector is d
to s DT squared times T plus Kappa D s
DT squared times n by the way this
entire recipe is derived in the texts I
have you do it again as a learning
exercise because I want you to practice
with this and I make additional comments
on this in the notes the the textbook
makes additional comments on it in the
text which is where you'd expect it to
be and all I want you to see is that
this is the same acceleration vector
that we were talking about in the last
lecture only now we're talking about how
it looks in terms of tangential and
normal components instead of I and J
components ok and what's so good about
tangential and normal what's so good
about tangential and normal is that
you're now moving along the curve rather
than with respect to some isolated X and
y coordinate system by the way in the
last unit we show the rather interesting
result that if T was any function vector
function of the scalar X and the
magnitude of T was a constant then DT DX
was perpendicular to T that was an
exercise in the last unit now the
interesting point is that the modern
approach to calculus says this why
should we single out the XY plane after
all you can be given a particle moving
through space or you can be using a
different coordinate system the natural
parameter is Auckland consequently the
modern approach never talks about the
angle fee or anything like this but
modern approach simply says this look at
define the unit tangent vector as before
since the TDS because the magnitude of T
is a constant since the TDS is already
perpendicular to T let's define a second
vector n to be the magnitude to be dtds
divided by its magnitude again the same
old trick what have we done here we have
simply taken dtds which we know is
perpendicular to T
a scalar multiple of dtds will still be
perpendicular to t but now this is what
it's a unit vector because we've divided
this vector by its magnitude therefore n
is a unit vector and where is it it's
perpendicular to T if we now cross
multiply
notice that the TDS is equal to the
magnitude of the TDS times n see just
cross-multiply I now claim that the
magnitude of D TDS is just D feed yes
now why is that I guess I should have
planned this better but let me come back
to the previous board over here notice
that since T is a constant vector since
T is a constant vector how does it
change it can change in magnitude
because it has constant magnitude
therefore it's only change must be due
to Direction alone but the direction of
T is measured by feet in other words if
the TDS is changing at all in other
words if this is a variable it must be
changing only in direction because the
magnitude of T is always 1 in other
words T cannot change in magnitude it
must therefore change only in direction
in other words the magnitude of dtds is
the same as the magnitude of D feed es
recall that we just defined the
magnitude of the feed es to be Kappa and
therefore DT DS is Kappa n the same way
as in the traditional approach the
beauty of this approach is that were no
longer restricted talked to the XY plane
we're not restricted to any plane we're
not restricted to any coordinate system
we can now in fact generalize this to
Goyle into three dimensions and in fact
some of you will probably have enough
difficulty with what we've done so far
that you won't want to go into three
dimensions what I've done is I have made
up an optional unit that follows this
one a unit which has no lecture it
simply has a batch of exercises for
those who have mastered the material in
this unit and we'd like to see what
happens in three-dimensional space and
after all when you deal with real-life
orbit type problems and things like this
notice that you do need the geometry of
three-dimensional space for this if you
so desire you can then do the optional
unit that's why it's called optional you
can skip it if you want there's no loss
of continuity if you should skip it but
that optional unit I devote
computational drill to what happens when
our curve happens to be a
three-dimensional space curve in other
words a curve that winds through space
notice by the way that in the same way
as before I can write R of T is X of T I
plus y of T J plus Z of T K where that
is the vector form of the curve in
Cartesian coordinates given in scalar
form by the three equations X is some
function of T y is some function of T Z
is some function of T again my claim is
that if I just take the IDS I still have
the unit tangent vector and to see that
just notice what we're saying here this
is a space curve now I've taken a small
segment of it his are his R plus Delta R
so this difference is Delta R look what
look what happens as you take Delta R
and divide it by Delta s first of all
the direction of Delta R does become the
direction of a tangent line as Delta s
approaches zero so certainly we can
believe that the direction of DRDs is
going to be the tangential direction
also if we invoke the result of geometry
that we talked about in part one of our
course when we talked about sine theta
over theta as theta approaches zero the
length of the arc is approximately the
length of the chord for small segments
so therefore Delta R over Delta s in
magnitude approaches one
in other words DIDS is still the unit
tangent vector the same as before again
from a computational point of view to
find the RDS you do not rewrite this in
terms of s you simply do what you take
the R DT the same as before divide by
its magnitude and you automatically have
DRDs similarly once T is given to find n
you simply differentiate T with respect
to s and divide it by its magnitude and
again notice even though I've written it
again if you look back to the first
third of our blackboard this is the same
definition for n as before because our
original definition did not specify it
the curve had to be in a particular
plane see same general definition so I
now have
now what do tienen do tienen determine a
plane it's a plane which we call the
osculating plane to the curve that's the
plane which sort of touches the curve at
that particular moment though remember
this curve is winding through space and
again this is done in more detail in the
notes not quite as elegantly as going
like this but the idea is you have this
plane that's shifting along with the
curve the only thing that's missing that
causes new complications when you deal
in three-dimensional space is that in
the same way that T and n take the place
of I and J in to space you need
something that takes the place of K in
three-dimensional space what we do is
again look at the structure we mimic how
K is related to I and J and invent a new
vector called the by normal hence
abbreviated B which is simply defined to
be T cross n the vector that you get by
rotating the unit vector T into the unit
vector n through the smaller name with a
positive 90-degree angle all right now
what is B B is perpendicular to both T
and n in other words B is a vector which
is perpendicular to the osculating plane
since B always has a constant magnitude
because TNN are always perpendicular C B
always has magnitude 1 the point is that
the BDS the magnitude of the BDS
measures the twist of the curve in other
words that his this tangent plane
following a point a particle along the
curve and what you're saying is how fast
the direction of that tangent plane is
changing is measured by the BDS that is
called the twist I call it the twist I
put it in quotation marks because nobody
else calls it the twist the formal name
is the torsion see this is called the
torsion I talk about that more in the
notes the point being by the way that
notice that if the BDS happens to be 0
in other words if B happens to be
constant then the curve lies in the
plane we certainly recognize that for
example if the curve happened to be in
the XY plane notice that if if T and n
were where I and J I cross J would just
be K B would then be a constant
the derivative of a constant with
respect to any variable is zero and
therefore when the curve does lie in the
plane the torsion the twist is zero in
other words the torsion does for
three-dimensional space what the
curvature in the sense does for
two-dimensional space at any rate our
main aim is to get you familiar with
some vector calculus and if in doing
this we can also help you learn how to
use this stuff in some physical
applications that happens to be frosting
on the cake next time we are going to
talk about the fact that we still have
to invent additional coordinate systems
that I and J isn't enough T and n isn't
enough next time we're going to show why
we need polar coordinates but we'll
worry about that next time until next
time then goodbye funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate